let's have a look at puppy now let's
just let's just answer and the question
is will um all the points will arises we
actually solve it find the coordinates
of any points inflection okay so I'm
going to say points of inflection sorry
I should have done that points of
inflection now mark is okay you notice I
said stationery points exists when F
dash equals zero right no qualification
they just do they absolutely will every
time okay if you've got this you've got
this and if you put this you about that
okay do you remember last time I was
trying to point out not always okay I'm
gonna give you some counter examples
soon unless a points of inflection may
exist when the second derivative F dash
is equal to zero
okay they made it so I'm gonna solve
this thing I'm gonna say yep yep so I'm
looking for concavity now I'm looking
for when there is no contaminate cuz
that is a likely place where so they may
exist so I'm just gonna solve right in
other words 6x equals zero so x equals
zero no problem okay
it's because it's easy I'm just going to
work out the table of values people I'm
always going to do that I'm not even
going to work out where this is
vertically yet cuz I don't even know if
it's a point of inflection yeah so what
I don't need to worry about the y
coordinate if it's not even in
inflection I'm gonna draw my table
hmm
so now I'm not looking at the gradient
changing looking at the concavity
changing right so I still want the
plus/minus thing happening so I'm gonna
go this time X against f double dash or
a desperate one DX squared if that's how
the whole question was phrased it's not
in this case okay so I'm testing zero
right I'm gonna go minus one and one
okay again we're talking about
neighborhood tests right um I know
because of the nature of this function I
look at that thing it's it's acting very
very predictably so I don't need to
worry too much about being like I'll
test minus 0.1 and positive point one
like don't worry it's okay look how
simple the function is and I know what
these values you're gonna be minus C 0
and 6 okay so I can see a change in the
concavity because the sign has changed
just like it did for the first
derivative but now I'm looking for quick
Abby you're out of ingredients okay so
I'm gonna say I'm gonna come back over
here on the left
okay I'm going to say therefore your
concavity changes sign okay again that's
a critical statement to interpret this
right it's the equivalent of this
statement here I'm making a conclusion
about what number is tell me about the
shape they could have a change of sign
so now I'm going to find where it is
right so I'll say if of zero which I
believe it's zero right it's just goes
to the origin so I think it's execute
minus three X right to zero takeaway
here so I would say 0 0 is a point of
inflection sketch a graph of the
function indicating all important
features now the fun bit ok so you've
got all of those features named yeah
right so we're going to pop them and
we're just gonna join the dots but we
don't just join the dots we know about
what's happening at each of those dots
so we've got 1 comma minus 2 minus 1
comma 2
okay by the way as soon as you have
plotted those points you can see oh yeah
of course one has to be the maximum and
one has to be the minute because how
else are you going to get from one point
to the other but now you also know
there's going to be this point of
inflection right there in the middle
okay so you can know like not just it's
going to connect but how it's going to
connect okay so I'm getting something I
guess a little bit like no wait I'm
missing yeah yeah
so I cuz I rubbed it off so there you go
that's what we started with right so to
factorize I have this right so it's my
bad bad come on oh I don't need to
factorize any further further to know
what my x-intercepts are gonna be I've
already got one of the origin and plus
or minus root three okay so remember
I've fenced myself in in terms of scale
by saying that's 1 and negative 1 okay
so root 3 is about 1.7 so you want to
make sure that this is roughly in the
right spot so this is going to be
something like well that's that'd be 2
so it won't put something over there and
if that's negative 2 over some way like
that
okay so unfortunately this does make it
hot up because now you can't play so
fast and Luke we like it just goes
through there now you know all these
particular places that you pass through
right so you have to be quite careful
with it so that's right so here make
sure it looks exactly right
alright let's give it a shot shall we
I posted it on one
this is like I just said I mean it's
substantially harder than you've done
before because now we know substantially
more about this function that we live in
for okay now I'm almost there it says
sketch it indicating all imported
features when they say all the important
features ninety-nine percent of the time
they just mean telling that all the
stuff you just found they just put it on
there that's all it means
okay so I've already got the same max
turning-point there and I'll write it
screaming what nice okay right there
he's my minimum you found the point of
inflection you've found the point
inflection so you should say point of
inflection at the Orangery okay and then
you've got you've got rid so you've got
three three you've got negative that is
very unusual it's highly unusual this is
this the reason why I chose out this
question is because this is pretty
standard the earlier parts and they do
this in the HSC all the time right
they'll say okay find find this
determine HR find this like show show
that it is it's not enough just to do
that right and then say tada I found one
okay I'm going to give you the counter
example as soon as I finish this
conversation and then once you have all
of that you just put that onto there
like I guess I wouldn't expect you
usually after the labeling ready